since December 2018 China's biggest
company Huawei has been rocked by
political and legal turmoil Huawei a
company that a lot of Americans may not
have even heard about and so just
recently the FBI is investigating
Huawei's dealings with this tiny Chicago
area startup while we can create a back
tour to China the Trump administration
has been on a campaign to block Huawei
from selling equipment for 5g networks
in the US and to allies abroad claiming
the company poses a national security
threat speak to the company's customers
and they paint a different picture to
them Huawei makes reliable affordable
equipment without equal this is the
story of how Huawei went from a
small-time parts reseller to the
homegrown tech giant China always hoped
for and the West always feared I am
announcing that a grand jury in Seattle
has returned an indictment that it
alleges ten federal crimes by two
affiliates of telecommunications
corporation Huawei Technologies there is
clearly a full-court press in Washington
to make it seem as though hallway poses
a grave threat to the future and Western
civilization
literally and that's why you saw the
Commerce Secretary the FBI director and
the acting Attorney General of the
United States at a press conference for
what we're really not that serious a
charge Huawei's recent spat with the
u.s. began in December with the arrest
of Hmong wanju Huawei is CFO and
daughter of the company's founder then
in January the u.s. indicted the company
for theft of trade secrets conspiracy
and obstruction of justice stemming from
a previous lawsuit brought by t-mobile
Bloomberg Businessweek discovered that
January 28th the same day as the
Attorney General's announcement the FBI
raided a Huawei owned lab in San Diego
under suspicion that had stolen
groundbreaking smartphone class
technology from another firm but
huawei's troubles aren't anything new
having been accused by Cisco in 2002 and
Motorola in 2010 of intellectual
property theft
since 2012 major US telecoms have
essentially blackballed Huawei thanks to
government pressure which while damaging
hasn't done much to slow its progress
worldwide Huawei was founded in 1987 by
former People's Liberation Army engineer
Ren jingfei in Shenzhen at the time all
of China's telecommunications equipment
was imported from abroad ren wanted to
build a domestic competitor that could
rival and eventually surpass foreign
companies the company moved quickly from
reselling telephone switches made mostly
in Hong Kong to designing and
manufacturing its own equipment it's
early contracts with groups like the
People's Liberation Army gave Huawei the
government connections it needed to grow
and its high quality low-priced products
did the rest they're really good at what
they do they build very sophisticated
devices that power wireless systems and
cellular systems and telecom and the
sort of backbone of the internet the
networking environment and they do it at
a much lower price point better
equipment lower cost there are other
countries other companies primarily in
Europe that make this stuff but Huawei
is by far the price-performance leader
at the moment by 2012 Huawei had become
the biggest telecoms equipment maker in
the world
and in 2018 it overtook Apple as the
second biggest smartphone manufacturer
but what could be hallways biggest
success and what scares countries like
the u.s. so much is its role in building
the backbone of the coming 5g revolution
I think it has a lot to do with the
specific character of the 5g world it's
gonna be far more software driven which
is far more open to very hidden very
subversive very discreet backdoors that
I could allow malevolent States or
hackers or others to wreak all sorts of
havoc
to this end Congress has enacted a ban
on government agencies and contractors
purchasing Huawei equipment rendang Fay
and Huawei have always maintained that
the business is employee owned and they
would not cooperate with any
interference from China's government US
officials like to point out that they
may not have to cooperate in China
passed a law that requires and this was
in 2017
that requires all companies and all
individuals in China to cooperate with
the intelligence services if asked to
the China Hawks are saying well we don't
have to give anyone proof of past bad
behavior because with that law on the
books the potential is there for the
government to simply commandeer
following for its own purposes
5g tech will be far more prevalent in
daily life than anything we're used to
now and the country that controls or
builds 5g will simply have more
influence than they used to on a global
scale so China's long hope for tech
giant has finally arrived what remains
to be seen is how much more of the world
Huawei can conquer and if the US can
slow it down
[Music]
you
you